help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
let me jump to this story we got from
the post millennial
breaking connection that's right
connecticut assistant principal placed
on leave after project veritas expose
this is crazy this veritas expose from
the other day oh this is wild this is
totally wild this dude's basically
bragging about how he's breaking the law
to like
violating nondiscrimination laws saying
he won't hire conservatives catholics or
people over 30. people over 30 right all
of this is just meanwhile look at this
guy like why does he have a job that's a
good question
and he's like well these people they're
brainwashed and i'm like dude
when you refuse to expose people to
other ideas it's you that's the cult you
not the other people who are actually
okay with different ideas competing with
each other
but this guy's now placed on leave the
crazy thing is there's a video i think
you guys i don't know if you guys have
it where james o'keefe oh yeah that we
have that in a different story yeah they
ran like multiple stories on this james
confronts the guy at a bar or a
restaurant and they threatened they
called the cops and the cops threatened
to arrest him yeah yeah this is crazy
but this is it this is one school it's
one school in connecticut good job
project super fancy part of connecticut
i mean but just just you need to
understand that this is an example of
what parents need to be watching out for
he's basically saying he won't hire
someone who doesn't agree with trans
ideology he wants teachers to come in
and tell the kids whatever the kids want
to hear and what he wants them to say
and he's like i'm pretty good at making
sure we don't hire any catholics or
conservatives you can't ask them but you
can ask other things and then i just
call him and say you know we've moved on
to another candidate
this is what they're doing at your
schools man if you don't if you don't
keep an eye on what's going on you're
going to wake up one day and be like why
didn't my kid shave shave their head and
now they hate me
well i mean your kid can shave your head
and hate you without joining a
cult can't they yeah but what i mean is
i mean
that's like teenagers we've talked about
this a lot
the the cult indoctrination at these
schools especially at colleges and we've
had tons of people come on this show and
like while we're getting ready for the
show they're like yeah my kid's about to
go to college and i was like do you read
your own tweets yeah why are you doing
that they just because it's just no like
this is why i'm like i don't know maybe
there won't be a civil war because the
right will just sit there and shake
their fist while the left stage is a
revolution because even knowing the
schools are doing this they keep sending
their kids to these schools it's like
okay i guess sure fine whatever well it
is hard i mean as a parent it's hard to
try and like
figure out if there's a path that you
can take
you know i talk to my kid all the time
about all of these things home schooling
well micro schooling private schools you
got to do all of these things you got to
figure it out i'm just going to never
said that i'm just saying it is hard to
figure out a choice it's a full-time job
to figure out how to educate your kid
yeah no one ever said having kids was
easy yeah i didn't say it was easy my
son actually said like he wants to go to
college and i'm like you could also just
buy a truck i got an idea though
hear me out i i hear what you're saying
about it being a full-time job what if
we created some kind of like cultural
institution where there was a parent who
would
work and make money and acquire
resources while the other parent
principally helped raise those kids and
then through that partnership you'd have
like a a healthy family to raise these
kids and instill values in them you know
what i mean like what could we call
something like that i don't know maybe
like a fa family
family sounds like evil white supremacy
colonialism to me what are you trying to
control kids or something geez
the other thing too is i was recently
listening to or something i was
and somehow i was absorbing information
about
what
i don't know how about divorce about
like the history of divorce in the u.s
and i have come to the conclusion that
no fault divorce was a total mistake
this should never have been absolutely
not allowed at all
right yeah terrible i love this we never
should have done this media matters i
think it was media matters one of these
lefty outlets wrote like tim cast irl
the right wing is now coming for no
fault divorce and i'm like okay yeah
like what how do you protect against no
fault divorce as a guy as a woman too i
guess but like i have like you know i
i'm in my 40s i know lots of women who
are no longer married uh there's crazy
stories you know a guy wakes up one day
and he's like i don't want to be married
to anymore and then he takes the house
and tries to take the kids and you're
like what what did i do what happened
and the inverse yeah and then we've been
doing the same thing guy comes home one
day the locks were changed and she's
like here's the paper this is just crazy
yeah
i've heard but then i've been told like
they're not enough like even if you have
a prenup that says half of it if you
have to if you have to sign a prenup
like don't marry that person correct i
feel like prenup should be embedded in
the marriage contract so you don't have
to feel bad about it but that's crazy
too like then why get like what's the
point of
married to get divorced you you you'd go
money you used to not getting
and you'd be like i'd like to get a
divorce and then the judge would be like
no denied bank i think they'll get
counseling the idea of getting married
is i'll bring my 10 million you bring
your 600 000 and then with our 10.6
million we make 100 million more and we
split that but you don't get my original
10 million i love that like this 10
million brought to the marriage in the
first place i just remembered what it
was that i was listening to it was the
criminal podcast about this woman who
was trying to get divorced from her
husband after he had
been convicted of murder and she had to
go to south because she had to go to
south it was like i don't know sometime
before now she had to go to the
southeast
to do it right you know what i'm saying
like but then he was exonerated is what
happened and she could so she could have
potentially gotten the divorce because
he was in prison but then he was
exonerated his dad got him off on like
all these reasons uh and so she had to
go to south dakota and live there for
like a year in order to qualify to get
divorced because it was legal there and
then south dakota changed their law and
other people started having no fault of
force and whatever but yeah criminal
podcast i like that did you catch what i
was saying about the the prenup embedded
prenup the how i think it makes sense
yeah because then you don't have to
worry about it when you get divorced
leave
like marriage is a business contract and
you bring it up your initial investment
and they bring their initial investment
i don't see why they should have access
to your initial investment before you
know them kind of feel like considering
marriage as a as a business contract
defeats the entire point of marriage i
that's not how i would ever view
marriage as a business arrangement it's
just financial
then why do it
just so you don't have to get taxed when
you give your wife a hundred thousand
dollars a year i hate this idea of
marriage
i don't i don't that's all that's true
that's that's not what marriage is it's
just like i can give you more than
fourteen thousand dollars a year that's
just the gift limit and then it's i'm
not gonna so like there should be let's
choose your scenario i'm involved there
should be one oh yeah but
let's use your scenario about 10 million
dollars
dollars to start with like you should
probably be getting married in your
early 20s you know you're hurting the
taxes of the other person if you marry
them if you have that much money
unless you're if you're stuck if you're
stagnant if i come out with no no no no
no no no when someone when someone's
making you know 250k and they marry
someone who's making 100 million
making 25 million per year and now it's
a joint filing you basically have just
jumped straight up you have there's no
benefit received to the person who's
making less money they just get they
just get taxed more that doesn't make
sense they're also making 12.5 million a
year because they're married to someone
that's making 25. yeah but here's the
other piece of that is like if you're
both these
wealthy millionaires like
how do you even have time to find
someone to fall in love with like that
really is a business contract like
working to make a lot of money is
um maybe i'm just doing it wrong i
should clarify too because i think it's
a thing the highest bracket what's the
highest bracket it's 250 right 250 and
up i have no idea so it's actually like
if someone's making 50k and they marry
someone who's making 500 it's bad tax
wise it's like i mean i would not uh
encourage getting married and not trying
to make more money i think the purpose
is you're going to make at least 10
times what you're making alone if you're
married
i don't think it's bad tax wise
and i say this as a former financial
advisor because the 500 person can come
down to a lower tax bracket
right because well it would basically
put a a
half of their money they would get
another 125k towards uh deductible or
whatever or no no that's not how it
works it's um
it's
yes you're right right right like what
i'm trying to say is
the overall tax bracket might come down
but what i'm trying to say is if you're
acting as an individual who wants a
prenup it is bad for you to enter this
arrangement because it benefits the
person who has more money and depending
on how much money they have it may not
actually be a benefit at all for anybody
so what i'm trying to get at is the
system itself is being set up in such a
way that it really really disincentifies
me disincentivizes marriage like you can
lose true on the poor side too
i mean just across the board the whole
system is completely screwed up
but like if you're if you're poor
bring back the dowry that's what we need
right
you know the
i have linens from my great
grandmother's truso oh yeah that she
embroidered and brought with her into
her marriage i've been tossing around
getting married it's because i'm dating
this girl and i'm like i i want to give
her money every year but i don't want to
get taxed on it so like what's the only
way to do that is to have a joint bank
account it's basically you we can share
funds but i'm like it seems so cold and
calculated it sure does maybe that's the
way you're supposed to treat marriage
because it's all numbers it's not like a
love doesn't make love like that's up to
me i got to do that in my own soul
i think the one of the big problems we
have is that um regardless of whether
they're conservative actually no no i i
would i would say this um principally of
conservatives they are they are raising
their children extremely poorly now
granted they're doing better than than
liberals for sure what i mean though is
how is it that there are conservative
families that are shocked to find their
kids have become
you know purple hair shaved head
you know
left extremists who hate their parents
guts
that's bad parenting that's it i don't i
mean maybe it's bad parenting it is you
you kicked your kids off
and then we're like what happened to my
kids maybe you should have paid
attention to what was going on with
their lives i think for a lot of parents
today when they think of school we think
of our own experiences in school
and a lot of them just have no idea how
much things have changed these aren't
education centers
they're indoctrination centers and
people are getting blindsided it's not
even it's it's it's also there's there's
more to it we had um you know our friend
richie mcginnis his mom was on and she's
an old-school feminist and we tried
explaining to her that feminists today
are pro-war she was shocked said no
they're not yeah they are they all have
years
has ukraine flag in her yeah they want
they want to pump money into the war
machines correct they want raytheon to
see those record profits and they're
selling to sell a bunch of weapons to
taiwan too like exact billion dollars
yeah a billion dollar grant or whatever
for weapons but these older people don't
pay attention
they they've resigned from mot from
modern political and social life and now
the world's being burned down and
they're sitting back voting for it going
oh you're crazy it's not happening so
there are people who are like tim don't
rag on boomers
my friends i'm not ragging on you who is
intelligent smart who reads the news
fact checks and is questioning what's
going on and is watching the show and i
was watching the show i'm talking about
how we've had people on the show i'm
talking about
the the the large portion of boomers who
are voting democrat thinking they're
voting for like a hard work a union guy
and they're actually voting for child
sex changes and they won't read a single
article online to save their own
children's lives it's not just boomers
it's it's literally anybody but you know
i think the issue is
when it comes to the older generation
not just boomers but anybody they
consume television media that's where
they get their news we are online so
we're exposed to counter information
they're not so they sit there in their
in their lounge chairs watching cnn
going wow can't believe that's true
again and no matter how many times
there's a hoax no matter how many times
there's a new justice millet they
believe it
at a certain point you got to be like
okay this thing's just full yeah there's
a there is a sense of erosion that is in
in interplayed as well like it's not
people are not impervious to realizing
what's going on eventually sometimes
enough you know enough information
appears in their face they see enough
uh
genderqueer books or books about this
and that and seeing a 12 year old with
the mass double mastectomy and they're
like sometimes like an erosion can
happen slowly over time sometimes
all of a sudden a big piece of rock just
falls off and you're like whoa what am i
looking at the trick now is
are you familiar with black propaganda
the concept yeah so this is what the
left does
right
lying cheating stealing
and the right doesn't do these things
they they they try and take this
straightforward approach of here's what
has to be done and here's the harsh
reality you go to someone and say you're
gonna have to work hard to make a better
future they go hard work then the
democrats come along and say you know
those loans you took out we're gonna
make other people pay for them and
they're like sounds good to me freebie
right what they even say is that no
one's gonna have to pay for them they
lie about that too oh yeah yeah i'm
imagining what would happen
if you went door-to-door
knocking on doors in a swing district
and said that you were a democrat
you know voter
and you showed them the book genderqueer
and you said here here's a book here's
what's in schools
do you think how would people respond to
that
i think that i think that there's two
ways that they'll respond to it right i
mean some people would look at it and
they would say oh that's shocking i'm
going to start looking into this because
that's crazy and other people would just
say no they would do that thing where
they just don't even believe their eye
but that's why i'm saying you don't make
any arguments you don't tell them like
if someone just literally handed them a
book and said like i want to just like
you buy you the problem is you buy the
book and you're helping the person who's
making the book but i'm just wondering
like what would happen if you were you
know in a neighborhood handing out these
books like what would what would they be
saying about it the far left likes it
but the problem with democrats these
days and the democratic party is they're
essentially being held hostage by the
far left wing of their party
because if they object to any of this
there's
they are called a bigot and to be called
a bigot as a democrat is like instant
death it's like none of them will stand
up to them yeah blasphemer they're like
no not me heretics so they don't all
agree with copy of that book i bought a
copy of genderqueer because we were
writing about it a lot and i was like i
should just take a look at this book
um and the things that i found
horrifying about it had a lot less to do
with the graphic imagery and more to do
with the trajec trajectory of the story
by the end of the book this main
character who now is non-binary is
planning with a euphoric sensibility how
to come out to their students because
also
the character is a teacher now you see
like that's the weirdest thing to me
that
there are teachers who are like i want
to make sure all these children know who
i like to bang right why would you want
that no we don't even we we we would
never even say our teacher's first name
like if you went to your teacher and
said their name they'd be like excuse me
oh you did at quick yeah so i went to
several different kinds of schools i
went to public school for
er through eighth grade and then i went
to catholic school for two years
and then i went to uh quaker school for
two years
what was l.a quaker school
was great it was academically rigorous i
had teachers who
were old school professor-style teachers
where
any idea that you wanted to talk about
was on the table i was having trouble in
my my english class with uh peter ranka
and we called him peter but um
did we call him peter i don't remember
anyways i think i called him mr rinka
because i came from catholic school and
i was used to calling people's sister so
it was anyways who cares the uh my point
is i was having trouble in english class
and so i talked to mr anko about it and
he said um
well what do you want to read and i said
i'd like to read
this book the castle by kafka and he was
like great read that
and we'll make time we'll talk about it
after school
and that's what we did
and it was great
and my philosophy classes were
interesting and i took you know
independent studies and writing plays i
mean it was ludicrous if everyone could
go to
the school i went to the way it was in
the mid 90s
if everyone could go to that school
i wouldn't we wouldn't have these kinds
of problems to be honest thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you